à l'hôpital Pierre Boucher une cellule
de crise nationale et mobilisée et une
enquête ouverte depuis la découverte du
champignon mortel le candidat Auris deux
patients qui partagaient la même chambre
ont été infectées depuis le 8 septembre
trois autres patients ayant eu des
contacts étroits sont en cours
d'investigation ce microscopique
champignon s'attaque aux malades à
l'immunité affaiblie ils peuvent causer
des infections en général ce sont chez
des gens dans l'immunité est affaiblie
soit parce qu'ils ont une grave maladie
qui sont aux soins intensifs qui ont un
état d'immunosturation au départ donc il
se défendent moins bien ils peuvent
causer des infections relativement
banales comme une infection de peau mais
ils peuvent causer des infections
systémiques et dans ce cas là le taux de
mortalité quand même assez élevé une
personne infectée a de 30 à 60% de
risque de mourir une fois que ça
s'installe ça peut être difficile de
s'en débarrasser donc
pour ça qu'il faut essayer de limiter le
plus vite possible il y a plus de
travail à faire il y a beaucoup plus
d'échantillonnages du fait de du
candidat Auris en fait c'est sûr que ça
amène une charge de travail
supplémentaire du côté du 6 de la montée
régie est la porte-parole précise que
depuis le 8 septembre les équipes de
soins concernées ont été tenues au
courant des mesures à appliquer
l'éclosion a été confirmée le 20
septembre mais ce n'est que deux jours
plus tard que l'ensemble des employés en
ont été informés son origine demeure un
mystère mais le ministre fédéral de la
santé se dit préoccupé c'est quelque
chose qui préoccupe beaucoup de gens
depuis quelques temps et qui préoccupe
qui me préoccupe aussi et qui préoccupe
la santé publique fédérale et je leur ai
demandé de nous revenir rapidement
l'Institut national de santé publique du
Québec et mobilisé dans ce dossier aux
côtés du ministère de la Santé et des
Services sociaux ici Camille Faye zen
Radio-Canada Longueuil